now perhaps you've seen this viral video
as it's been circulating online over the
past several days in the video which has
been viewed tens of millions of times on
Twitter and millions more on Tik Tok we
see a D1 female track star Alana sabahan
racing some random guy in sweatpants and
the random guy is apparently the track
runner's boyfriend's friend she tells us
in the video uh the video of the race
which she narrated and posted to her Tik
Tok account that the friend had
challenged her to eras and supposedly
according to her the friend quote
refused to believe that a woman could
beat him in a Race So unsurprisingly the
woman did beat him in the race and you
know she's a D1 track runner and he's a
guy with no experience in track who
rolled off his couch and decided to race
this
girl apparently just for a laugh and he
lost um which is not a big surprise
here's the
video I am a D1 track tell about this
one time I for some reason raced my
boyfriend's friend over 400 me used to
believe that a woman could beat him in a
race he does not run but he challenged
me to 400 m and I only agreed because I
was doing a 400 workout already so I was
like sure join then he ended up bringing
both his parents his family his friends
and I was like what the heck did I get
myself into but to narrate what went
down I just ran the first 200 me with
him I just stayed with him I'm not
exerting myself for no reason I have
nothing to prove here if you're crazy
enough to challenge a 4800 athlete to a
400 race that's on you I'm not going to
correct you and then since he does not
run at all his his lack of Fitness
really hit him hard after 200 M and I
was like okay let me just go now and
then as you should always do I finish
hard because that's what you do as a
track runner and this was also one of
the Reps of my 400 workout so I'm just
doing my workout here so yeah there's me
pushing hard actually felt some lactic
um and then uh yeah so the Gap was
widening I actually ended up running 57
for this which is pretty good for
practice now uh that video has been
celebrated by feminists and trans
activists all over social media they're
very excited about it the feminists see
it as a great girl power moment where a
woman puts a man in his place and the
trans activists see it as a proof that
there's no real difference between the
Sexes and there's no reason why
biological males shouldn't be able to
compete against women um now in fact as
I will explain the video is actually an
embarassment for both groups it does not
make their case it undermines it but
don't tell that to the media which has
been fawning all over this story as well
Alana's race against the random dude has
been reported by dozens of media Outlets
uh today.com published an interview with
the runner which so they because they
felt like they had to interview her and
uh just reading part of it here's what
it says a man who challenged division
one track and field athlete Alana sabak
Khan to a a foot race was swiftly
defeated in a viral video that
illustrates why female athletes should
never be underestimated sabakon 22 tells
today.com that when she first heard
murmurings that her boyfriend's friend
thought he could outrun her she found it
ridiculous but when she was already set
to work out at a nearby track she asked
if he wanted to join he didn't really
know what to challenge me in she says he
was like yeah I could beat her in the
400 not realizing that that was one of
the hardest track events and that was
one of my secondary events Alana whose
main event is the 800 meter race
finished the 400 meters in 57 seconds
which was quote pretty good for practice
she said in the video her personal best
times are 53 seconds for a 400 met of a
relay and 54 seconds in an open race
now okay wait just a minute here she
said that she barely exerted herself and
ran a 57 against the guy but she also
says that her personal best is a 53 so
running a 57 when your absolute personal
best is only 4 seconds faster than that
means that you were definitely exerting
yourself okay don't like this was not a
casual
jog uh if your best is a 53 and you run
the 400 and under 60 then you you were
trying okay you were definitely trying
but we'll get back to that in a moment
the today the today article now veers
off into a kind of Woe Is Me tale of men
disrespecting female athletes and this
we're supposed to believe is a real
epidemic quote it was far from the first
time sabakon who started running when
she was 5 years old had been challenged
to erase by a man quote ever since I was
younger a lot of guys would want me to
erase them on the playground because
they thought that they could beat me she
says early reactions to the suggest to
sabak Khan that this was a universal
experience quote a lot of women were
saying that they experienced that a lot
mainly men trying to challenge them in
their sport or Talent or whatever they
do she says in fact 12% of men in Great
Britain think that they could score a
point playing tennis against Serena
Williams according to a 2019 poll
conducted by uh yugov UK which sampled
17732 adults sabakon eventually turned
off comments on the the Tik Tok page
after it stirred controversy with with
some turning it into a debate over
whether men or women are better athletes
okay I'm I have to confess I'm a little
confused here I mean what was the point
of that tidbit about 12% of men in Great
Britain thinking they can score a point
against Serena Williams 12% is a very
small
number so uh if the premise here is that
men are overconfident in their athletic
abilities and always disrespecting
female athletes so much so that this is
a universal experience for women then
12% doesn't really make the
case I mean 12% is hardly
Universal and also by the way like a a a
certain portion of that 12% of men
probably could score a point against
Serena Williams not not maybe not beat
her but score a point so this article is
stepping all over the point it's trying
to make which is consistent with the
pattern that we see emerging here Grand
Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian univers University
based in Phoenix Arizona they are
dedicated to making education fit into
your already busy schedule which is why
they offer 270 of their academic
programs online from scholarships to
academic support gcu's graduation team
provides you with the personal support
you need to obtain your goals gcu's
online programs offer you the freedom to
earn your degree on your own time from
wherever you are GCU is praise for its
culture of community giving and impact
they integrate the free market system
and a welcoming Christian worldview into
all of their academic programs achieve
your goals with a personalized plan and
a supportive team behind you find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu let's go back to
the video this is a highly trained D1
female track star running hard enough
that she finishes with a Time 4 seconds
off of her personal best and yet she
only beats some random dude off the
street by it would appear like 5 Seconds
at most
um which which in in a track race like
if you're actually racing track uh uh 5
seconds is a pretty good
amount but keep in mind that the only
thing the man has going for him is that
he is a man he's not a runner he's not
an athlete he's not trained he has no
experience with track and field he's
just a guy and that's it and that alone
was enough to keep him within Striking
Distance of a D1 female track athlete
now just to kind of make the point clear
imagine how this race would look the
other way okay imagine some random woman
off the street challenging a D1 male
track athlete to a 400 meter race it it
it wouldn't she would not come within 5
Seconds okay she would not be uh they
would not be on the same straightaway on
the track at the same time like it
wouldn't happen the guy would be
crossing the Finish Line while the woman
had barely made it halfway around the
track at Best in fact we can make it
even easier for the woman in this
hypothetical scenario so imagine a D1
female track runner challenging a D1
male track runner and for that we don't
need to resort to hypotheticals because
the truth can be seen in the numbers so
let's go back to the uh 2023 NCAA
outdoor track championships which
happened in June the winning male runner
in the 400 event finished with a time of
4424 seconds which is nearly 10 seconds
faster than Alana's best time um or
twice as as much as she beat the other
guy by the guy who finished eighth in
that uh Championship uh match had a time
of
45.3 which is nine seconds faster but I
mean let's be fair Alana doesn't claim
to be a division one Champion she just
says she's a division one you know
Runner so let's compare those times to
the actual female Champions first place
among the women finished with a time of
49.2 so if you're keeping track at home
that means that the fastest woman on the
track was 4 seconds slower than the guy
who finished eighth but it gets better
the women's world record for the 400
meter dash okay the fastest time ever
recorded by any woman ever in history is
47 .6 seconds and that record has stood
in place since
1985 for nearly 40 years the fastest
time by any woman anywhere in the world
ever is
47.6 which means that the eighth place
finisher for the men in the NCAA
championships in 2023 beat the women's
world record by two seconds but it gets
better still because the the women's
record was set by a German Runner named
Marita Cook and Cook has long been
suspected of using steroids okay 47.6
seconds two seconds slower than the
college kid who finished eighth among
the men last June is seen as so
unattainable for women and has proven so
impossible for any other woman to even
come close to beating that it's assumed
probably correctly that it was achieved
with the help of performance-enhancing
drugs but we still are in time okay
Alana's personal best again is 53
seconds um
we've already established that she would
get totally annihilated by her male
College counterparts only we don't even
need to limit it to College Alana
attends the University of Virginia and
just for fun I went to check the times
for Virginia High School Runners and so
here for example are the results for the
boys 400 meter race at the class 6 State
High School championships last year okay
first place finished in 48.1 seconds
which fun fact would have been fast
enough to win the gold medal in the
women's 400 meter race at the Tokyo
Olympics this is a high schooler 17th
Place among the high school boys
finished at 5133 which means that Alana
on her very best day would not finish in
the top 17 among High School boys in her
State okay so to review the fastest high
school boy in Virginia is faster in the
400 meter race than the woman who won
the gold medal in the event at the last
Olympics and the fastest College male is
significantly faster than the woman who
set the world record for her gender a
record that has proven so untouchable
for four decades that most people assume
she was on drugs and Alana is slower
than all of them though she's still
pretty fast you know fast enough to beat
some random guy off the street by four
or five
seconds so what does this all prove well
it proves that uh basically exactly the
opposite of what the feminists and trans
activists were hoping to prove with this
story it proves instead that men and
women are very different and men are
vastly superior in almost every sport
which is why men and women should not
compete against each other in those
Sports men are faster and stronger than
women on average a lot faster and
stronger a whole hell of a lot faster
and stronger so much so that no woman in
history even ones hopped up on steroid
have run a 400 time that would have
placed them in the top eight at the NCAA
men's championship last June so uh
there's no competition here like there's
nothing to talk about though we are
still forced to talk about it we
shouldn't have to talk about it all
things being equal I would rather not
spend my time explaining that men are
better than women at sports I would
rather not have to go and pull up all of
these like times and information and
provide actual citations just to prove a
thing that everybody in the world has
known until 3 seconds
ago and and so we could end this
conversation we could all move on if you
people you on the left would just stop
with the nonsense already and simply
admit what cannot be denied as long as
you're running around making idiotic
claims about how men and women are the
same and men have no biological
advantages then the sane Among Us will
be forced to continue correcting you we
can't simply allow your idiocy to go
unchallenged so cut the crap and drop
the ACT admit that men are faster than
women and men are stronger than women
men are not women admit it or we will be
compelled to continue embarrassing you
as I have just been forced to do here
again and just remember as this happens
that it's all your fault and also that
you are today canceled if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there goded